Welcome to this demo video. Hello, welcome to this demo
video of how to install Cognotic desktop on Windows. Simply
go to cognotic.com. And download the
installer file or you can go to GitHub. Under releases
and see all of the installer artifacts. I'm going to
click on download for Windows. Save this file. Because
it isn't commonly downloaded, you may have to manually keep
the file. Before you open it to install
it, install it like any of the install it like
any, And
there we go. Next, we need to configure the application
We go to Cognotic in the Start menu. Run it
now. This is a server-based application, so when you run
Cognotic from the Start menu, this is starting the server
You have to go to the taskbar, click the server
icon for Cognotic, and that will open a browser page
From there you need a login. This is a system
local login that's used to secure your API credentials, so
If you don't have one already, you can easily register
for this. I'm just going to say fubar. And for
password, I'll say test. But weak passwords, but it will
allow them, except for space. It won't allow space. When
you register It will launch a confirmation dialogue which unfortunately
sometimes doesn't come up on the top, so you have
to find it with Alt tab. This is to prevent
people over the internet, for example, potentially creating and
using your service. You say yes And
now we have access to. We need
to go to settings to add our API key. We
have provider. It supports a number of different providers, but
I mainly use and therefore mainly recommend Anthropic and Gemini
Teres Don't say that. And the password manager
need to re refresh the page first. Test a basic
chat, and we see haiku, haiku anthropic. That means the
models were discovered. It probably works, but let's do the
full test. Hi. All right, now
we have Cognotic fully installed, configured, and tested, and we
are ready to run one of the applications.